President Biden arrives back at the
White House
on the schedule yet another phone call
with the Speaker of the House
in which is confirmed that the budget
agreement is now ready to move to the
full Congress the speaker and I made it
clear from the start that the only way
Ford was a bipartisan agreement
that agreement now goes to the United
States house and to the Senate I
strongly urge both both Chambers to pass
that agreement let's keep moving forward
on meeting our obligations and building
the strongest economy in the history of
the world optimism 2 from Kevin McCarthy
who dismissed reports of discontent
among Republican house members saying a
conference call on Saturday indicated
the majority were in favor of the
agreement well that's okay because more
than 95 percent of all those in the
conference were very excited but think
about this
we finally were able to cut spending
we're the first Congress to vote for
cutting spending year over year
but there are conservative Republicans
who argue the budget cuts are too modest
and equally there are Progressive
Democrats who insist they are too
stringent
there are some in these opposing flanks
that may well vote against the bull the
question is whether there's enough
moderate support on both sides of the
aisle to push the legislation through in
both the house and the Senate
the grave consequences of a default
could be an energizing factor for
bipartisan action there's a ton of
partisanship and it makes it very
difficult uh in various serbic in
Washington
um but I think this is when all said and
done when you close the doors and get
the principles in the room there is
still some capacity for the parties to
reach decisions
granted again with a that sort of
Damocles hanging over their head because
it really both sides agreed it wasn't
acceptable for the government to have a
default the legislators will have 72
hours to read the bill and the aim is to
hold a boat in the house on Wednesday
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington
now the two journalists who first
reported